we're nearing the end of teacher
appreciation week 2018 this is the first
full week in May each year there's a lot
of celebrations and blog posts and
videos people talking about how
important teachers are in our life and
you know I'd never thought that I would
myself become a teacher let alone you
know a college professor and then you
know whatever it is that I'm doing
beyond the professor at here with my
YouTube videos and online classes and
talks and all of that sort of thing
there were quite a few teachers that
were important and influential in the
course of my life
and I as I thought about that you know
I've told a lot of stories in videos and
talks and sometimes online events about
a few of these people I thought it would
be a good idea for me to introduce those
of my subscribers and viewers and other
fans to some of these other people who
made a big impact on my life and are
probably in some respect responsible for
me doing the kind of work that I'm doing
today or at least being fairly well
adjusted in many respects so you know
when I was thinking about this I
couldn't come up with anybody from my
elementary school days and that's not
because you know elementary school was
terrible or I didn't have any good
teachers it's probably due in large part
to a lack of memory but a lot of it also
has to do with the fact that they didn't
know what to do with us gifted and
talented kids back then this is the
1970s right in the middle of it so they
just kind of you know put us off on the
side and gave us stuff to work on with
very minimal guidance that was part of
the I think the educational philosophy
of the time and so we didn't have a lot
of interaction with with teachers and I
mean they were nice most of them but
they didn't really make much of an
impact on me I can't say that there was
one however mrs. Scott she was a math
teacher
she was also she'd been an emergency
room nurse so she would tell us these
these terrible stories that I found you
know pretty fascinating but most of the
students were grossed out about the
things that she'd seen in the emergency
and one of the things that she actually
did that was good for me I was you know
very bright and and I learned
mathematics from my father well before I
even got to elementary school I was
already doing in a multiplication and
division and working with negative
numbers and so by the time that I was in
elementary school I was so advanced that
they just gave me work to do and sent me
off to the side and I learned how to do
division in in one way and then I was
supposed to learn how to do it in
another way which would be better for me
the way that we actually do you know
division by hand and I don't even
remember what the first way was but I
was so good at it that I wasn't
progressing I wasn't learning the new
material so my attitude was hey I'm
doing fine with this I'm keeping up with
all the other students who are using
this better tool why the hell would I
you know learn the new the new approach
so she sat me down and said listen I'll
make you a deal and you know we're gonna
go through a bunch of these these
problems and if you can beat me I'm
gonna do this this method you do this
method that you like so so well if you
can beat me I'm not going to make you do
the the other long division you can do
whatever you like from now on but if I
win then you have to start doing this
and so you know predictably enough I was
fast but not as fast as her and and it
was good that somebody sort of set me
straight about that but that's really
all I can say from elementary school now
in in middle school I went to a private
Middle School which you know it was an
interesting experience maybe I'll do a
video about that sometime it was the
kind of place where you tended to either
be rich or smart and there wasn't a hell
of a lot of overlap between the two
there was some and you were very very
conscious of the class structure that
was built into it but you were also
getting a pretty you know good education
you know we learned Latin in 6th and 7th
grade and then went on to another
language we were way ahead in
mathematics and science and so I was I
was getting some challenge
and we you know for our soccer coach we
had a former Olympian teaching us and so
I really enjoyed soccer so that was cool
but none of that had to do with the
teacher who I would say made the
greatest impact on me in middle school
and that was mrs. Becca Dale she and her
husband mr. Dale were and though maybe
he was mr. beacon I don't remember they
both work there
and she taught drama and she taught
English classes and we had to take drama
every single year as I remember 6th 7th
8th grade and you know we started out
with some some really interesting
exercise she was very good at what she
did and here's what made the biggest
impact on me so my dad found me writing
a play and it was not a very good play
at all what I look back at it it was
largely drawn from Lloyd Alexander's you
know chronicles of prettyand which is a
fantasy series for young adults about
this you know guy Taryn and had a lot of
sort the the play as I wrote it had a
lot of sword fighting in it a lot of
fighting the bad guys not a hell of a
lot of dialogue as I recall but I was in
the process of doing that my dad found
me do it doing that in my my room and he
said let me take a look at what you've
got there and he took it to mrs. bika
Dale and she said well this is pretty
good we're gonna put this on this is
going to be the play for our first
semester sixth grade and I didn't know
you know most of these other kids you
know but I got to know them in part
through being the guy who had written
the play and she would ask me well what
did you envision here what do you think
about this and of course I was much more
interested in you know having sword
fights and stuff like that but she you
know she was trying to teach us how to
conceive of characters and how to act
and then later on I had her not only for
drama but also for one of the English
classes
um you know she taught us literature she
she was I remember one time she actually
got very angry at us as a class and it
made a big impression on me I think it
was seventh or eighth grade there was
some poem and it was about a bull lowing
for the the the you know the the hammer
or you know the other cow in the field
and it mentioned something about his
balls of course we all broke out
laughing and she got she got upset with
us but she got upset for the right
reason it wasn't that she was being a
prude or something like that she was
like listen this is just natural stuff
this is not something that you should be
getting so worked up about you're not
getting what's happening here in the
poem it's distracting you from paying
attention to you know the literature and
you know I didn't see a lot of that sort
of thing I saw a lot of prudery
when I was a kid I saw a lot of joking
around I didn't see a lot of people who
took thoughts literature ideas so
seriously that that was their focus they
could get angry they could be joyful
they could be sad about that sort of
thing and that made a very big
impression upon me it's sad to say but
none of the other teachers at ULS made
any real positive impression on me lots
of them made negative impressions but
you know and I could tell stories about
them but there's there's nobody who
really influenced me now when I got to
Catholic Memorial High School it got a
bit better
actually there were three teachers in
particular who made a big impression on
me and I'll actually talk about one who
you wouldn't think about you know
necessarily in terms of teaching but who
probably had in in some respects the
greatest influence on me and that's my
gym coach and and track coach Chuck Bobo
Charles actually but he went by Chuck
and he was for me and I think for many
other young men
Catholic Memorial and probably for a lot
of young women to sort of a model of
intelligence athletic and ethical
masculinity I remember the first day of
class gym class he put us all up on the
bleachers and he gave us a lecture red
in the face
you know shouting at us a triplets into
our head to impress upon us that we were
not to pull the bra straps of girls
anywhere in the school I guess this has
been a big problem the year before and
he wanted to stress to us that you know
there was a functional equivalence in
terms of pain and discomfort between
testicles and breasts and that if he
caught us doing anything remotely you
know untoward to any female students
with respect to their breasts we were in
deep trouble and and you could you know
you had the sense that this guy was very
serious about this and again it wasn't
about prudery it was about fairness and
trying to get us to think about other
people before we do stupid actions now
of course all of us were studying it's
like what the hell is this guy yelling
at us but you know he was he was kind of
an unusual gym teacher at the time many
gym teachers back then were kind of
jerks they were very macho very
sometimes even sadistic you know
encouraging you to use any means
necessary to win Bovo was all about
fairness and and there wasn't any sort
of like well it's okay if you if you
lost because you played the game right
he didn't go that far
which he shouldn't but he stressed that
it was important to actually follow the
rules and do things the right way even
today when I when I workout I sort of I
don't hear his voice in my head but I
but I these words keep coming up to me
don't cheat yourself and that was an
important aspect to it wasn't just don't
cheat the other people don't cheat the
coach don't cheat the game don't cheat
yourself don't deprive your
self of what discipline would would
actually make possible for you if you're
doing you know a rep do the rep all the
way the right way if you're running you
know and you've got to do eight 100-yard
dashes do every single one of those the
right way and if you if you fail on one
do it again and and you know I found
this was so important for me outside of
the field of athletics that mentality is
what allowed me to learn foreign
languages the way that I did this you
know needing to drill and drill and
drill I I learned that more from I would
say from Chuck bova than from from
anybody else and and I was learning it
in a different context so you know that
was he was another very important
teacher another one that I can think of
is Robert reuleaux people call them Bob
but you know he was actually very formal
I had him for creative writing my first
semester he would say you know quite
biting sarcastic things in class but
he's a very good writing teacher and
then I had him again for British
literature and he was the kind of guy
who you could tell was was quite serious
about his his subject matter and he you
know he could sometimes be a bit of a
martinet you know and the chickens are
done people are finished sort of stuff
but I remember coming to him after I had
you know graduated from college gone and
graduated from high school gone into the
army come out I was writing some poetry
and bringing I brought the poetry to him
and I remember he asked me tough
questions about he I said what do you
think about it he said now this stuff
isn't very good and I was sort of
crestfallen all right and and then he
went on to tell me why it wasn't very
good this point this point this point
and I remember very well I had a line in
there about you know sort of losing my
philosophy meaning sort of losing my
sense of where I was going in life and I
remember him asking me the question why
should that matter not just to you but
to the reader why should they care at
all about whether you've lost your
fear not and he wasn't saying it to me
to brush me off he was saying it to me
to try to provoke me into actually
thinking and then writing something a
bit more fully to articulate myself the
other person who made a massive impact
on me and and probably is the one who's
responsible for me having a
philosophical vocation in the first
place I don't even know his first name
he was a substitute teacher who came in
for one semester from Seattle mr.
Lorenzo and he taught a sacraments class
and he taught st. Augustine to us he
said he replaced a nun who would have
probably been terrible as a teacher and
he said Augustine you know changed my
life I converted because of him and
reading his confessions and going
through you know what I'd gone through
in Seattle I want to introduce him to
you he is the saint for sinners and he
talks about the sacraments and then he
said now before I can actually teach you
about st. Augustine I'm gonna have to
explain some Plato to you because Plato
is very important and then we need
Aristotle as sort of a counterpoint to
to that and then we can talk about the
manna Kea you know Manichaean religion
that that Augustine was in for a while
and then we can talk about Augustine and
we actually had a little bit of time
left at the end of the semester so he
was like you know why you've seen it was
a psychologist let's talk about Freud
Jung and Adler so he taught in a way
radically different than any of the
other teachers you know there was no
rote memorization we didn't have a
textbook he would you know put stuff up
on the chalkboard and then we would talk
about it and we'd ask questions most of
the other students hated it because they
had no idea what was coming up on the
exam and they they viewed his classes
unnecessarily you know confusing and
difficult I thrived in it and I was
getting to see what philosophy could
really be like because I had a
philosophy class at Catholic Memorial
and it was pretty bad it you know it was
the sort of thing that had that been my
only experience with philosophy would
have told me I
I never wanted to go into that field so
mr. Lorenzo another very important
teacher in my my high school career then
I went to Lakeland College which is now
Lakeland University and there were there
were three professors who really made a
big impact on me
interestingly none of them were
philosophy professors instead they
thought other stuff there was Lucretia
Crawford who was my writing instructor
in freshman year we had to take
expository and persuasive writing I was
a good writer and she more or less
allowed me to do what I wanted to do but
I had to keep within certain guidelines
and you know when I think about the work
that I made for her you know in
persuasive writing we had to eventually
culminate in writing a research paper it
was supposed to be about like 10 to 20
pages or so I wrote a 70 page paper
double-spaced you know and I wish I
still had it you know to take a look at
it and it was essentially about whether
television was a good or bad thing
that's kind of a big topic I was doing a
lot of research and I made the case that
that in many respects television was
actually a bad thing but it could be
harnessed in different ways she actually
read that entire paper and gave me
feedback on it she let me write the
paper in the first place I mean a lot of
professors you know a student you know
who's got a paper that's spiraling out
of control they'd say rein it in buddy
I'm not reading that that stuff you know
but she she understood that that was
something that I had within me and could
do so she she she encouraged me and then
later I one of the best classes I ever
took from her was a a winterim class we
had this this special winter session
where you'd meet with with you know for
a month three hours a day five days a
week and we read our ways through the
Arthurian literature and boy did she
come alive I mean she was already a good
teaching writing classes but when it
came to teaching literature especially
literature that she was so fond of the
the enthusiasm and the rigor that she
brought to it was was really quite
impressive she gave me a model for what
what scholarship and teaching would look
like when they're fused together another
professor who again I don't know his
first name his last name was Ron under I
believe it's been a long time
he was actually an adjunct he was just
there for a few semesters teaching
history and I don't remember exactly
what class I took with him first but I
remember a really great winterim class
that was on the history of the American
West
I actually took enough history classes
that I probably could have triple
majored if I'd wanted to but I decided I
wanted to get get finished you know as
quickly as possible but rahmanir was
closer to us in age and he was a really
interesting guy he had graduated from
our cat which was just down the road you
know from from here and not that far
from from Lakeland College and he was
kind of burnt out at the time so he told
Marquette's placement office which
actually existed at that time nowadays
these these don't really exist anymore
to find him a job as far away from
academia as possible so they put him on
the Lakota Reservation where he taught
history in a very impoverished high
school for several years and lived on
the reservation and got to you know know
the life out there and you know
continued doing research of his own he
was a very interesting guy to talk to in
the classes and then he and I would
often hang out afterwards you know I was
an older student he was a younger
professor so we'd you know hang out
either on the campus pub or you know in
Howards Grove down the road and bum
cigarettes off of each other and drink
the cheap beer the hunt app and talk
about history
talk about how you did history how you
carried out historical research and you
know he was sort of a model again of
competency and you know interest in his
his subject
he was also rather you know sardonic guy
in many respects perhaps that might have
rubbed off on me a little bit at the
time I think it probably had a good
nerve of that going already but he was
he was a really interesting guy to
interact with and then you know the last
professor that I'll talk about I didn't
actually take any classes with and he's
retiring this year from Lakeland College
his name is Mara bond Kota Von D and
he's Iranian he taught in psychology and
education and I never did take any
classes with him although he did give a
guest lecture on Zoroastrianism in our
comparative religion class at one time
but I interacted with him all the time
and you know we would chat about this
and that and and I sometimes go into his
office and sometimes we'd you know meet
up at events and he was just such a
good-hearted genial guy I'll tell you
something else about him that that's
really touched me quite a bit so I've
been gone from this area here Wisconsin
for 20 years and I recently you know
moved back here with my wife who's also
from the area and Lakeland College asked
me to give a think house talk on anger
and what we can do with it and that
involved me going up to campus several
times and while I was there I went in
Old Main where the faculty offices are
and I you know I was walking around
seeing who's there who's not metal it
met up with a couple other professors
who I thought were pretty cool
and there was mayor bond co2 Von Teese
office so I I went over there and I said
I wonder if he's gonna even know who I
am and I walked in and he looked at me
for a minute now this was
graduated in 1994 so this is more than
20 years ago he looked at me and many he
said oh how are you doing Greg he'd
remembered our conversations that we had
you know when I was you know some sort
of bright but in many respects probably
kind of naive and you know brash and
dumb student he's that kind of guy
and so you know he always impressed me
with with with his his character he was
the kind of guy who's always doing good
in one respect or another so that was
Lakeland College then I went on to
graduate school and I would say there
were there really three professors there
who influenced me the most one of them
actually left he didn't get tenure in
part because he didn't publish enough
while he was there and I took six or
seven classes with him his name is
Andrew black younger guy from from
England and he taught modern philosophy
and he was analytically trained but he
was very interested in the history of of
the times and how the people fit into
that and again it was sort of like
Lucretia Crawford in that he saw that I
could do some things that some of the
other students couldn't in part because
of my use of foreign languages and the
access that that gave me to other texts
but also because of the sort of you know
philosophical work I was I was capable
of so in some and sometimes he would
sort of get out of my way and let me do
things and then you know try to make
sure that I would get reined in at the
appropriate points he'd asked these
questions like well that's all very
interesting but what's your evidence for
that or you know I remember he was the
one who I asked about to lose and I've
used this line several times I said
because we were talking about live nets
and Deleuze had this wonderful book the
fold and I said what do you think about
the lose and it is you know history of
philosophy books and he says well
Deleuze is quite clever but I think that
you're getting a lot more to lose than
you are Spinoza
or niche or a liveness or whoever else
he's picking and he's completely correct
about that andrew was a great you know
sort of promoter of scholarship
unfortunately like I said he didn't he
didn't publish enough early on he was a
great teacher by the time that I got to
taking his classes and that's where he
put a lot of his attention so I was very
sad to see him go
the another professor who made a huge
impact on me at the time and and
probably even still down until today it
was eventually became my mentor
Garth Gillen and Garth actually by the
time that he left Southern Illinois
University had three advanced degrees
one in philosophy one in theology and
one in educational psychology when he
retired he opened up a clinical practice
and is still doing it today as far as I
know we've actually I haven't been in
touch for quite some time his classes
were very exciting because he taught
contemporary continental philosophy and
mostly French stuff some German stuff he
was very big on Adorno he actually
taught a class too on Karl Rahner
believe it or not but he'd mostly do
things like you know teaching dari da or
you know Marilyn Paul tearful call or
people like that and his approach to the
texts was intensely hermeneutical we
would take the text and try to figure
out what what is going on in this
passage what are all the reference
points and and we would sort and then we
bring it back to whether any of this was
actually true he was also very
interested in Jacques Lacan he's he's
one of the people who got me interested
in him but he always stressed the need
to figure out how much of this is
[ __ ] how much of this is actually
applicable and usable and so he was he
was he was also kind of an upstart you
know he was a Catholic Marxist from way
back he'd grown up very blue-collar out
in Montana
so there were a lot of ways in which we
could relate and is an interesting guy
who's kind of on the outs with the
department one when I first got there
and I was actually his last doctoral
student he retired shortly before I was
able to finish my dissertation so I had
a co-chair but he was officially the
chair then the third person who really
made a big impact on me without really
meaning to do so was actually Thomas
Alexander and he he was a person who did
classical American philosophy and also
some ancient philosophy particularly
Plato he was a Dewey scholar but he
wasn't a optimistic Dewey in the way a
lot of the Dewey people are he in some
respects he was more you know leaning
towards you know like Santayana and and
James and people like that who are a
little bit more pessimistic Dewey you
know you get this kind of rah rah rah
you know everything is going to be great
pragmatism will lead the way Alexander I
think was somebody who appreciated both
sides of the American pragmatist
tradition and I remember you know
getting good advice from him at crucial
points in my career as a graduate
student and I think in part because he
was somebody who like me could be you
know hot tempered and also hold grudges
and things like that so I think he was
counseling me out of experience you know
and he would he would give me advice
that was quite helpful for not allowing
my emotions to run away with me and lead
me into taking stands taking positions
that would would have closed doors for
me later on every bit of advice that I
got from Alexander even though I didn't
necessarily want to hear it at the time
turned out to be really good
vice and he's somebody who I've come to
appreciate more and more and more the
longer I've been out of Gretch it's cool
and I think you know the times when I
was in his classes and what a pain I
must have been as a graduate student but
he's you know he's somebody who made a
made a big impression an impression that
grew over time the last person that I'll
talk about is not somebody who I studied
with in in any of those schools it was
rather in a faculty fellowship that I
did as a young scholar
in 2005 if I remember right and that is
Alistair McIntyre McIntyre is you know a
very big name and and there was this
opportunity to do an Erasmus Institute
faculty fellowship at Notre Dame with
him in the summer and he was going to be
you know focusing on rational choice
Theory Aristotelian Thomism and Freud
and Lacan and I was like oh I'm gonna
apply for that definitely so I did and I
got hit I was the most junior scholar
involved in that there were 10 of us who
got selected and they put us up at Notre
Dame and fed us and then each day we
would meet with MacIntyre in these
seminars and you know we had to do
projects of our own and had the
opportunity to interact with him
afterwards and MacIntyre you know he's a
guy who does virtue ethics and he's
somebody who not just talks the talk but
really really really walks the walk very
much so he comes out of an old Marxist
tradition eventually you know becomes an
Aristotelian that an Augustinian that
it's homeless you know becomes a
Catholic along the way does some very
interesting work and I remember I would
see him that at you know conferences and
he would come up and he'd just start
chatting and here's the one thing that
you can say about MacIntyre and you can
say about many of these other people
who've been in port
teachers for me he's not what in
biblical terms you would call a
respecter of persons that is somebody
who really cares about the rank or the
prestige of somebody and isolates
themselves off with that person and
ignores everybody else McIntyre does the
opposite as a matter of fact I don't
know if he's still teaching at this time
at Notre Dame but at the time that I was
interacting him with him fairly
regularly
he was only teaching undergraduates even
though he could if he wanted just he's
graduate students and just teach the
subjects he wanted he was teaching core
classes because he said these are the
most important students these are the
most important classes again somebody
who made a very big impression on me so
all of these people I would say are in
some sense responsible for you know
better or worse the kind of guy I've
become I've drawn a lot of lessons from
them some of which have articulated to
you many of which I don't even know if I
could articulate to myself because
that's the way people make impressions
upon us but I wanted to honor each and
every one of them during this this week
devoted to you know honoring teachers
for the work that they do so there you
have it those are you know the people
who've made the biggest impression on me
through their teaching
you